so that's gone you certainly well first
of all is a Western so you want to think
about what makes sense you know going to
the Western and of course they asked
with Ryan and the cactus County cowboys
and so we thought well let's have
expanded and use those instruments you
know and then you we figured out well
what else do we need on this to keep as
an hour and a half it's very long and
you don't have that many songs my first
thought was how many songs can we write
with just five notes because the
pentatonic scale is a you know useful
for this kind of thing we actually used
more than that I believe we used 13
separate notes where the 13th one came
from you can tell to you don't add them
well what my job in this whole
conglomeration here was to provide some
of the transitions between the thorough
composed songs and what my job is to
incorporate the things that they
composed and try to weave it so that it
it underscores the action that is on the
screen yeah the the process was we saw
the picture we realized that you need
some heroic themes you need some love
themes or least one you need grow theme
a number of comical themes for the
comical events and characters who
inhabit this sprawling story and and so
I came up with a bunch and it came up
with a bunch we threw them together flip
coins and we saw which one's worked the
best and Dean filled in the rest you
know he will at the live element tonight
I'm mr. grout when I heard that the
Academy was going to be doing the
covered wagon I thought hmm will Ryan on
the cactus County Cowboys would be
perfect for that because first of all
the on-camera instruments that you see
are banjo fiddle some rustic guitar type
implements such as the humidifier
and which is kind of unusual and what
else just kind of stuff we had in the
band also in the band we're very lucky
we've got some people who can play all
kinds of things we've got saxophones and
harps and other things that we aren't
using tonight but within the band itself
we have all of those elements and we
have generally as a cowboy band the kind
of instrumentation that that would be
perfect for an 1848 adventure arm some
of us tend to write kind of a 1848 type
song this kind of the non-italian it
more pasquin odd carnival ah the
carnival ases if you will minstrelsy
type stuff that's it how's it end other
than I don't know you'll have to see a
movie and fog
you